MATT ROGERS: Hey,
how's it going?
I'm really excited to be here
and talk about the next API.
It's a long time coming.
How many of you guys signed
up to hear about this probably
about eight months
ago at this point?
Exactly.
OK.
Waiting for a long time.
And I'm really glad to be
able to talk about it now.
We've been working on
it for about a year.
And I think we have fully
thought through this,
kind of built an entire
comprehensive program.
And we're going to talk through
quite a bit of it today.
So things we're
going to go over.
We're going to go over details
of the API, kind of high level
what the features are, and
also go through some examples
as to how to build to it.
Mark's actually going to walk
through some sample code.
Design.
Some design
guidelines as well as
some tips of the
trade of things we've
learned over the
last couple years.
And some details on
how we should test,
and how we are going
to test your apps.
So when did this all begin?
It began in a garage.
So we started in a garage about
three years ago in Palo Alto,
off Alma Street.
And this is back in the
day when hardware was dead.
No one was going to build
anything in hardware.
No one was going to fund
In fact, I think the story was
that the days of the hardware
startup were long over.
But we've grown.
And we've built a business.
We've grown
considerably since we
started three and
a half years ago.
And we have a whole campus now.
So if you're down in Palo Alto,
there are three Nest buildings.
And actually, we've
totally filled them up now.
It started with a thermostat.
And people laughed
once upon a time.
Like can you build a company
reinventing a thermostat?
It turns out you can, and you
can do really well doing it.
It started with
the idea of can we
reinvent these
unloved categories?
Can we bring design,
technology, connectivity,
learning to a category
that has none of that?
And it's really exciting to see
that there's an entire industry
now around reinventing these
unloved things in the home.
Actually, how many
of you guys are
interested in building
products for the home?
See, that's amazing.
If I had asked that
question four years ago,
probably three hands
would have gone up.
So that's amazing.
An industry has
been created now.
And I think we're in
a really good place
to work together on this.
I think with Nest critical
mass and your brains,
I think we could build
some really cool stuff.
So taking the
thermostat Nest Protect,
about a year ago we decided
we really need to do an API.
We're hearing from you guys.
We're hearing that
it's time to do it.
There's an untapped
set of products
that we can never go build.
Nest can only do so
many things on our own.
Yes.
Nest will continue to
build great products.
And we've got a ton in
development right now.
I'm really excited
to share soon.
But as you can
imagine, there's a lot
we could do with just
what we have today.
So what is the
Nest API all about?
So one, of course, it's
about controlling thermostats
and things like temperature
control, home comfort.
And there's a lot
of things that we've
done so far with home comfort.
And we've added
features continuously
since we launched the company.
But there's a lot
more we could do
and things that I hope that
people will go pick up.
Protect event.
So we launched Nest
Protect last fall.
And it's really about safety.
And this is a brand new
category for us and things
we've thought a lot about.
And I think for this
first generation of APIs,
being able to listen
to Nest Protect events
and figure out other things
you do with those events.
So I don't know if you guys
saw some of the examples
that we've launched,
but these guys LIFX who
have built a connected
LED light bulb
listen to Nest Protect events
and flash the lights red
when there's an
alarm in the house.
I think it makes a lot of sense.
I'm curious what
other kind of things
we're going to come
up with with this API.
Home and Away,
extremely powerful.
And this is something that
we've taken years to develop.
We have automation
around Home and Away
where people don't have to go
and push a button to do it.
So being able to
listen to those events
and know when people are gone
from the home automatically, as
well as with the user's
input saying, hey, I'm gone.
Things can happen at my
house now that I'm away.
And when I'm coming home,
do something for me.
ETA.
So piggybacking
on Home and Away,
but actually
providing some input.
So a really popular example
that we've heard from users,
and that we've launched
now with the API
is, hey, I'm driving home.
Why can't my house know that?
So we partner with
Mercedes Benz.
They were kind of an
early beta of the API.
And what they've done
is the super cool.
So as you're driving
home, the car
tells Nest, hey,
Matt's on his way home.
He'll be there in 30 minutes.
Make the house
comfortable for him.
It's super cool.
So it's all about the home.
And everything about
Nest is about the home.
I guess we get a
lot of spillover.
People use our products
in light commercial,
and small businesses, and
restaurants, and shops.
But most of this program
is about the home.
And most of what we
do is about the home.
So we've built an entire
program around revolutionizing
the home.
So some high level
details of the program.
So all the information on
developer.nest.com, very, very
detailed specs.
So we've had an
entire team working
behind the scenes for
the last four months
documenting the APIs,
building sample code,
going through examples, really
getting into the details
so that you could pick
it up and just go.
We're available.
We actually have an entire
developer support team
behind the scenes now,
ready to answer questions.
And we've actually put
something up on Stack Overflow
for people to ask questions.
So a simple answer.
But we put a lot of resources
on developer.nest.com
for people to learn more.
We're working with anybody.
So not just large companies like
Whirlpool and Mercedes Benz.
But small developers, too.
Individuals who have an idea
who want to get started.
We work with everybody.
And we've designed the program
to be extremely cross-platform.
So any connected product-- be
it a hardware products, iOS,
Android, the web, a pure
service, the Nest API
should work with everything.
We've designed it to be
extremely cross-platform.
To the point of, not
just cross-platform but
cross-product and
across industries.
Here's some examples of some
of the early partners who've
been working with us behind
the scenes on the beta
to make sure this
program is rock solid.
For the last four
months, these guys
have been working with
us behind the scenes,
and I think what they've
done is really cool.
How many of you guys were able
to check out some of the demos?
We had an event on Tuesday.
Anyone check out the demos?
Nope?
Couple of you guys?
We actually put together a
video that I'll go through
in a bit kind of explaining
what some of these integrations
were able to do.
Super cool stuff.
And things that we could
never have done alone.
So we have lots of ideas.
You guys do, too.
I'm really curious when
we put our ideas together,
what we'll be able to do.
So completely cross-platform,
companies big and small,
and also no hardware
changes required.
Like any internet
connected product
should be able to
work with Nest.
I think this is a
really important thing.
And you may have heard about
other home ecosystem platforms
that are emerging, like
something from the fruit
company down the street.
And you may imagine that
some of these things
are light on details,
but I can imagine
it's not going to work with any
hardware out of the box today.
I think this is really important
for especially products that
exist today.
So with a software
update, you should
be able to work with Nest.
I think that's really important.
It's also open today, so unlike
other products down the street,
you could go and
work with Nest today.
You don't need to wait.
So Nest is in three
countries today.
US, Canada, and UK.
We're expanding rapidly.
And this program,
will expand with us.
So we expect that as Nest
expands, and will expand,
throughout Europe, throughout
Asia, throughout the rest
of the world, the Nest developer
program will go with us.
And we'll establish
developer communities
throughout countries as we go.
It's an incredibly
comprehensive program.
I think we've thought
it through end to end.
So it's not just about the
APIs and the documentation.
It's about marketing
and about logo assets,
so you could put
things on your box
or on your website to
say you work with Nest.
It's about having resources
that are behind the scenes
to help you build
your ecosystem.
And also, I don't know if you
guys saw that, we announced
a fund with some of
Nest's early investors,
that I'll talk about in a bit,
to help small companies get
started in this industry.
And, again, we will work
with everything from apps,
to connected appliances,
to connected coffee cups.
I'm sure some of you
guys are probably
working on connected
coffee cups right now.
We will work with everything.
And we're really excited to see
what those products could do.
All around the
world, the home is
the center of people's lives.
It's where you start your
day and end your day.
It's where you raise a
family and make memories
with the people you love.
So wouldn't it be cool if our
homes could be more aware?
If our homes could learn from
us and help take care of us?
At Nest, we do just that.
It all started with the
Nest Learning Thermostat.
Then came Nest Protect.
But for us, that was
just the beginning.
Our goals has
always been to bring
this kind of thoughtfulness
to the rest of your life.
That's what Works with
Nest is all about.
Works with Nest makes it
possible for your Nest
thermostat and smoke
alarm to interact
with the things
you use every day.
Because we make connections
between these different parts
of your life, we can deliver
personalized comfort, safety,
and energy savings without you
having to do a bunch of work.
We've been working with
companies big and small
to make this a reality.
And we're very excited about
what we've been able to do.
TRAVIS BOGARD: UP is a
combination of a band
that you wear around your
wrist and an application
on the phone that,
together, help track
your movement
throughout the day.
By connecting your
UP and your Nest,
you can have this complete,
effortless experience.
Because UP's right
on the body, we
have this rich, contextual
set of information
about what the person's
doing in the moment.
And so that means those
days that you might wake up
a little bit earlier, before
you even get out of bed,
we can let Nest know that, so it
can then adjust the temperature
in the room to start
to be for my daytime.
This Is about technology,
not for technology's sake,
but technology in
service of a better life.
Helping us be more human.
Allowing us to live
our lives better.
MARC BITZER: Why would we ever
bring the thermostat and washer
together?
That's a good question.
If you look at it from
the perspective of energy
consumption, it's an easy one.
These are big energy
consumptions at the home,
and they are also ones
which require a lot of day
to day interaction
with the consumer.
If you have already the
thermostat communicating
to your utility company,
it's much easier
for one signal
going to the Nest,
and that is disseminated through
the house to all appliances
to basically reduce consumption
now, because we're at the peak.
It's just a tremendous
consumer benefit
that just happens
in the background.
PHIL BOSUA: LIFX
is a LED light bulb
that you control
with your smartphone.
When we first heard about
the Nest developer program,
we were really excited
to be a part of it.
With Nest Protect and LIFX,
when the smoke alarm event
is triggered, we can
pulse your lights red,
which can help you
see in the dark
as well as give extra
notification that there's
a problem in the house, which
is especially good if you're
hearing impaired.
Nest brings this whole
other dimension to LIFX.
Who would have thought by
combining Nest products
and LIFX products, we
could help save lives.
JOHANN JUNGWIRTH: The
automotive industry
is in a very deep change.
I foresee that in
the next 10 years,
the changes are going
to be more substantial
than in the last 50.
Likely, your car today
interfaces with your home
through the garage door opener.
After learning about the
Nest developer program,
we thought about, how can we
take this is the next level?
How can we integrate the
car better with your home?
As you get into your
car and drive home,
the car will, in the background,
send the estimated time
of arrival of your
Nest thermostat
so your home can be at
the right temperature
as you arrive at home.
Taking workload
off of customers,
it will improve safety,
it will increase comfort,
because people just
don't have to think
about all these things.
It's just great, like
magic in the background.
MATT ROGERS: At Nest, we
believe these experiences
are the future.
We're able to connect things
inside and outside your home
to better anticipate your needs.
We're doing some pretty
incredible things,
but this is just the beginning.
And we can't wait
to see what's next.
Pretty cool stuff, right?
So you can see what we
mean by building out
the conscious home.
It's not just about
building connectivity.
It's not about just
building products
that connect to each other.
It's about building experiences.
And as some of these
early partners can show,
there's some amazing
things that we could build.
So I'd like to invite
up Mark McBride.
So Mark McBride leads
the development team
that actually has built the
Works with Nest program.
And he's going to talk to you
about some of the examples
and how to build apps.
MARK MCBRIDE: Hello.
Thanks for coming.
Is Matt said, we're
going to talk about some
of the specifics around the API.
We'll talk about how
we're authenticating users
and protecting user information.
Walk through some sample code.
Talk about some UI guidelines.
And talk about some
of the testing tools
we've built to make
putting together
client applications super easy.
As Matt covered, right now,
Nest sells thermostats and smart
smoke and CO detectors.
And these two things
have a primary function
that they execute in the home.
The smoke detectors,
monitoring your environment
for smoke and CO and
setting off alarms.
The thermostat's doing the same
with the actual environment
and controlling HVAC systems.
But given the sensors
they have, there
are secondary functions
they can perform as well.
And we use that to determine
things about the home itself.
So our data is not
just device specific,
but it's also home specific.
The other thing that we thought
about when we were building out
this program is you're
not always at home.
When you're outside
the home right now,
Nest has some capabilities.
But our partners can
offer us a lot more.
And so we built the ETA API
as something totally new
that allows partners to tell
us when they're coming home.
We'll talk about some of
the specific devices now.
The thermostat has
about what you'd
expect from an HVAC
control system.
You can monitor current
environment of the house
that it's in.
You get access to target
temperature controls.
To HVAC modes, you can operate
the fan if one's in there.
And all the things you'd expect
from a regular thermostat
control.
What's interesting
about HVAC systems
is they're surprisingly
complicated.
You'll notice in the
API documentation
that current temperature
is not a writable field.
That one's read-only.
Target temperature's writable.
There's a variety
of systems that we
operate to make sure that target
temperatures are achieved.
There's emergency heat, there's
multi-stage compressors,
there's heat pumps,
there's radiant heating.
All of those things
work together
to make your home comfortable.
But there's things you
can do to them to put them
in situations that are
pretty nonsensical.
It's a lot of power, it's
a lot of responsibility.
Where possible, we're trying
to absorb that responsibility.
So our API has
safeguards built in.
If you try to put the
environment in a state that
doesn't make sense,
you'll get an error.
We won't let you do something
dangerous to the home.
So when you're building these
integrations, just watch out
for things to come back and say,
you're not allowed to do this.
There's usually a
textual descriptions
that you can interpret and make
sure you don't do that again.
Also with the thermostat,
and we realized
about a year and a
half, two years ago,
that we had access to a device
that controls the largest
energy consumption
source in the house.
So we partnered with
energy programs, utilities,
around the country
to provide what's
called rush hour rewards.
On hot days,
usually, when there's
going to be peak
demand on the grid,
an energy company
can tell us, we
would like some load shed
between certain hours
so that we don't have to
start up coal burning, usually
dirty, power plants
to meet peak demand.
We've made this available
to our partners, too.
Because while HVAC is the
largest energy consumer,
it's not the only one.
And we'll talk about some
demos and some integrations
our partners have done around
that a little bit later.
The Protect right
now is pretty simple.
It has alarm states, it
has battery level states,
and it also has an
overall device state.
So in our UI, we paint the
smoke detector a single color.
We don't have lights for
smoke, and CO, and battery.
Rather than have
all of our clients
try to interpret those
three different alert levels
and try to come up
with the right color,
we have an additional field
that's overall device state
that you can use to keep
your UIs in sync with ours.
We don't have a
lot of constraints
around how you use our data.
But in particular with Nest
Protect, it's a safety device.
And when users are looking
at data from this device,
it's likely an emergency.
And we don't want
people to be confused.
So we do ask that the alert
levels provided by the API
are the ones you use in
your client applications.
Don't try to reinterpret these
as, get up, get out, et cetera.
Just use the text
we have in there.
So we talked about the primary
and secondary device functions
we have.
The most prevalent
or probably the most
used one we have right now is
what's called Home and Away.
So we have PIR sensors or motion
detectors on the thermostat
and on the smoke detector.
And using those, we can
make pretty good guesses
about whether somebody
is in the house or not.
So our structure has a
field that's called Away.
There's two different
subdivisions of this.
There's manual
away and auto away.
Manual is exactly
what you think.
The users has explicitly
said, I'm home, or I'm away.
We won't use sensor data to
override any of those states.
The user said what it is,
we take their word for it.
There's another state
called auto away.
And if this is
enabled on devices,
if we don't sense motion for
a certain period of time,
we put the house into auto away.
And the difference
between that and manual
away is when we do
sense motion, we
take the structure out of away
and put it back into home.
Currently, we use this
to control temperature.
If people aren't
in the house, we
have secondary
target temperatures
that are usually more
efficient but less comfortable.
And we'll revert
to those settings
until somebody comes
back to the house.
You can use that for a wide
range of things-- turning off
the lights when people
leave, turning on lights
when people get home.
But we do ask that you respect
kind of manual away versus auto
away.
Auto away is an algorithm
that we've built,
and we've put a
lot of work into.
So while we're giving
you the capability
to set home and
away explicitly, we
ask that you do that at the
specific request of the user.
Not to try to duplicate
a secondary auto
away algorithm outside of Nest.
So we talked about ETA.
And this is something that's
brand new for the developer
program.
The ETA API is effectively
a stream of arrival time
estimates that come
from a partner.
So this makes a lot of sense
in the context of automotive.
You have a nav system.
You have a waypoint.
If that waypoint
is the home, you
have a stream of
estimated arrival times
that come from GPS, et cetera.
You keep giving us streams.
We evaluate that stream
for confidence levels.
If people veer off
course, they stop for gas,
they have something
else to do, we
want you to keep streaming
us those so that we
can take action when
it's appropriate.
When we trust that
somebody's going
to be home at a specific time,
we'll take appropriate action,
make sure the home's
comfortable when people arrive.
This is an indication.
As the car moves
closer to the house,
we want arrival times to
continue to be streamed.
Once we see that
it's in the range,
and we trust the estimate,
we'll take action
to take the house out of away.
So we've talked about
the APIs we're providing.
Let's talk a little bit about
how we're protecting user data
and making sure that all
of this stuff is secure.
The data we're providing
is pretty personal stuff.
It tells you whether
you're home or away.
It tells you what temperature
it is in the house,
whether there's alarm states.
We're using industry standard
OAuth2 for communication.
Everything's over SSL.
There's no opportunity
to do cleartext.
Every user that's exposing
data has to explicitly do so
with a fine grain
set of permissions.
So as a client, you can't
get access to all the data
unless you explicitly
say, my client
needs access to all the data.
You can instead ask for, I
need to read thermostat control
data, which gives the user
a more comfortable feeling
that you're not asking
for away states.
You're not asking
for alarm states.
All you really want to do
is look at temperature data.
In addition to the standard
OAuth2 mechanisms for this,
we're also requiring developers
to provide justifications
for each scope they need.
So in a case of Whirlpool,
who needs access
to rush hour rewards events,
they would say something like,
we would like this data so
that we can put the washers
and dryers into a more efficient
mode during rush hour rewards
events.
We're also providing a very
high level of transparency
to what clients are
doing to user's accounts.
And so in our energy view, we
will decorate all modifications
that clients make to target
temperatures, to Home and Away,
with the client
application name.
So if my Mercedes sets
an ETA on a home, when
we pull the structure
out of away,
it will say, done by
Mercedes Drive Style.
And this gives users
great visibility
into which clients are
integrated, because sometimes
people forget.
And what they're actually
doing to the account.
For integrations that
are more passive,
we also have an
activity log per client.
So users, at any time, can go to
Settings in their applications,
see all the integrated
clients, and see the last time
they connected to
the Nest service.
So here we're going to walk
through the typical sign-up
flow.
If people have
used OAuth before,
this should look
incredibly familiar.
Here we're starting from
a Whirlpool smart app
or an illustration of the app.
This will say something
on the Whirlpool side,
would you like to connect your
Whirlpool devices with Work
with Nest?
Here is the awesome stuff you're
going to get once you connect.
This takes us to
the Nest site, where
you see that Whirlpool would
like to see the temperature
and settings on your thermostat.
And the light gray
text underneath
is text provided by
Whirlpool to justify
why they need
access to this data.
Scroll through all that.
If the user says yes,
we authenticate them.
Make sure that
this user actually
has permission to
expose that data.
And then it'll return you
to the Whirlpool app, which
has settings for that
specific integration.
So that's how we secure data.
We'll talk a little
bit about the mechanics
of actually getting to the data.
We wanted this to be real time.
And this was something that
we talked about internally
quite a bit.
The easy way to do most of
these APIs is typical REST.
RPC, connect to the
service, tell me information
about the thermostat, I'll
do some stuff with it.
But that's not what we
do for our applications.
If you look at the
Nest applications,
when you change target
temperature on a mobile device
and watch the thermostat,
that interaction
takes place in
less than a second.
In fact, customers call
support when it takes longer.
So we can see
service degradation
through customer support
calls, because they'll
call up and say, hey,
it took me 20 seconds.
For the thermostat,
it's a convenience.
For the smoke detector, it's
not so much a convenience.
It's more critical
safety feature.
When the smoke
detector goes off,
we want to be able to relay that
information as quickly as we
can to all the integrations
around the house.
It would be a little weird in
the LIFX integration example,
if your smoke detector went
off, and 30 seconds later,
when the polling hit, the
lights started blinking red.
So we wanted to
provide this capability
to our client developers.
But real time APIs
are usually harder.
And we didn't want to do it at
the expense of having everybody
have to learn a new, complicated
network programming model that
was going to have a
steep learning curve
and be fragile at
best on both sides.
So we looked around.
And Firebase happened to be
doing something almost exactly
like what we do for our clients.
And we thought it would be
a great opportunity for us
to work with fairly standard,
open, documented, well
supported clients that we didn't
have to deliver ourselves.
In cases where Firebase
clients don't work,
we do provide a REST interface.
We also provide an event
source based interface.
So you can still be
real time, if you're
willing to adopt a slightly more
complicated programming model.
This gives us the capability
to work almost anywhere.
If you can use SSL,
you can use our API.
So this is a picture
we have today.
Typical clients,
developed with Firebase,
talk to Firebase servers.
With the Nest
developer program, you
use the same Firebase clients
on iOS, Java, JavaScript,
you just talk to Nest servers.
All right.
So we'll go through
some example code.
And this is pulled from
some of the early people we
worked with to
flesh out the API.
And so some of the use
cases you saw in the video,
we'll go through
sample code to show
how you can implement
that yourself.
I will preface this by saying
I'm like the world's leading
authority on not being
good at JavaScript.
So don't judges this
so harshly on style.
But I think it's
indicative of what people
can do with a little bit
of spare time and access
to the Nest developer program.
So Whirlpool.
Large appliances, large
energy consumption,
listening to rush
hour rewards events,
putting things
into a more energy
efficient mode when
peak periods hit.
Most of our samples
start off like this.
I make a connection to the Nest
developer API using a Firebase
client, and I
authenticate with a token
that's been provided
by the user.
We use this ref.on to set
up a listener for changes
to data at a location.
So you see in this case,
we've connected not just
to the developer API root
API, but we've actually
connected to a specific
structure that that user owns.
Here we say, get me the peak
period start and end times,
get the current date, and
then just compare times.
If we're in a peak period,
I log into the console
and see peak period.
You do something amazing to
remove energy from the grid.
If the peak period
is not in effect,
we just log that
it's not in effect.
So pretty straightforward.
Mercedes, different use
case with the ETA API.
In this case, we have
a car going home.
Something on the
index system pops up,
says 30 minutes from home.
We say heat it up, confirm.
And then the thermostat takes
appropriate action, preheating.
So this example is
a little bit more
complicated,
because like I said,
we have to send this
stream of ETA times.
So it's not just going
to be a one shot,
go through, set a value.
But we'll try and
walk through it.
Same thing.
We connect to Firebase.
Here, once again, we're
connecting to a structure
and authenticating.
We have people set
a unique trip ID,
because multiple people may be
coming home to the same house.
So we want a unique
set of arrival
streams so we can take
the house out of away
at the appropriate time.
We're going to set
up a function here
that takes an array of
estimated times of arrival.
Pop the first
element off the list.
Create an estimated time that
that person's going to arrive.
This is an array of
n minutes from now.
Then we take a trial value
of the structure called ETA,
and we set a value
with the trip idea
as the unique one we calculated.
And the arrival window begin and
end to the same estimate time.
We do allow the
flexibility to have
a window of arrival time
in case you're not sure.
In the case of a
car nav system, they
don't provide much
delta on either side.
And then we just set up
a timeout in JavaScript
to set the ETA for
the rest of the array.
And so this just calls
itself recursively,
popping elements off
the list every minute
to set arrival times.
And then we just
call the whole thing
with a simulated set of
arrival time streams.
Little more complicated,
but not crazy.
Jawbone's use case is pretty
straightforward as well.
The wristbands know
when you go to sleep.
They know when you wake up.
With Nest devices, we
have motion sensors
around the house,
but typically not
in the bedroom in a
real time capacity.
So this allows you to get
better presence information
or activity information
into the Nest API.
So the comfort of
your home can be
set earlier than it
would be if you just
walked by the thermostat.
So in this case, we sense
motion on the Jawbone wristband.
That makes a call
to the Nest service
and sets a target temperature.
So let's walk through this.
This should look very
familiar by this point.
Connect to Firebase,
authenticate with a token.
I'm going to compute
a wake up time.
This is setting an alarm
earlier in the evening.
Set the timeout
for when I should
set my target temperature.
And pick a target temperature.
Usually this is presented
in the UI of the integration
we're doing.
This call's a little
bit different.
This is not ref.on,
this is ref.once.
So Firebase also allows
you to just get data
once and process it.
This won't be called
every time data changes.
This will just be
called the first time.
And this shows
how you would walk
through all the
thermostats in a structure.
So for each thermostat, set a
time out to change the target
temperature at the time
I'm going to wake up.
Pretty straightforward.
The last one we have is LIFX.
This one is using
the Nest Protect APIS
to respond to changes
in alert state.
When it senses smoke,
it can change the lights
to blink red, which gives people
better visibility in smoke
and also provides
visible queues for people
who are hearing impaired.
So again, this will
look really familiar
for the first couple lines.
Oh, no.
It changed.
Look.
Here we're going to set
up some functions that
set lights and blink lights,
but now it looks familiar.
So we connect to Firebase, then
authenticate with our token.
All right.
There's more code.
Here we call once again.
And we're going to walk
through all the smoke
detectors in a structure.
And here, we're
actually going to say,
for each smoke
detector, I'm really
just interested in
the smoke alarm state.
So set my callback
just on that one.
I don't care when
battery level changes.
I don't care when CO changes.
Although we probably should
blink lights in that case
as well.
But this shows that you
can listen to specific data
elements in this
document and not
have to respond to
the whole thing.
And here, I basically
say, if it's warning,
why don't we blink
the lights yellow.
If it's emergency,
set the lights to red.
If it's all clear, set
the lights back to white.
So it has four integrations.
Somebody who's not
very good at JavaScript
was able to whip this out
in 30 to 60 minutes total.
I actually ran them in a
browser, and they worked.
But they're pretty
compelling use cases,
we think, for integrating with
data provided by Nest devices.
And really, really
extending the reach
of what we can do with
a more responsible home.
Next we'll get into
user interface.
We have a detailed
section on UI guidelines
on developer.nest.com.
And we'll just touch
some high points here.
We don't want you
to build Nest apps.
We built those.
We think they're pretty good.
We'd like you to build your
apps based on Nest data.
The only things that
we ask you to respect
are there's a few key things.
home and Away are very critical
concepts.
And so we prefer that
those stay Home and Away.
And Nest Protective Event
States, like we talked about.
Those are security
things, safety things.
We don't want to confuse users
in the case of emergency,
and don't try to be too cute
with the house is on fire.
There's also a
list of trademarks.
Logo usage, et cetera.
There's a whole page on
it at developer.nest.com.
When you get ready to launch,
I suggest going through that.
Testing.
Nest devices are really, really
simple from a UX standpoint.
Really, really
complicated for the kinds
of hardware they actually
have to work with.
And we touched a little
bit on the complications
of HVAC systems earlier.
But when we're thinking about
this, if we hand developers
a physical thermostat
and say, why don't you
test all the corner cases?
You're going to have to
wire the back plates to like
75 different combinations of
has cool, has heat, doesn't
have cool, has a common wire.
So we've created
a Chrome extension
that allows you to create
what we call virtual devices.
And the capabilities
of virtual devices
are extended to allow
you to physically
modify the wiring--
not physically.
Virtually modify the
wiring of the device.
So I can create my fake
device, I can set it up
with an air conditioner,
run my tests.
I can take away the
air conditioner,
which on the actual
thermostat would
be the equivalent to
pulling it off the wall
and removing a wire.
Which allows me to test a
wide range of permutations
of hardware without having to
set up a really crazy test lab.
We also have measures in place
to protect both the devices
and the service, to make sure
they're available for everybody
all the time.
And so we have two different
types of rate limits.
The first set of rate limits
are designed to protect devices.
Our devices are
highly constrained,
they're stealing power from the
HVAC system at really, really
low current levels.
And so you can't make
an unlimited number
of modification
requests to thermostats
and expect them to
continue to function.
So when we think the device
is getting into a state
where it may not be able to
execute all its functions,
we'll start rejecting
developer requests.
So if you see something
that's a 429 response,
or an error code in
Firebase that says,
device can't services this
at this time, it's time
to back off.
These rate limits, because
they're protecting the device,
are shared across all
client integrations.
And so this is a
little bit different
than a lot of the
ways rate limits work.
If a customer has
100 integrations,
in each one's making one
request a minute, a lot of them
are probably going
to get rejected.
The second set of
rate limits we have
are to protect the
service itself.
And these are per client,
or per access token.
These are typically
around the REST API.
We do have a limited number
of modification requests
you can make.
Those are device specific.
But forget requests
on the REST API.
Each connection
that's established
burns a little bit
of CPU and bandwidth,
and so we limit you
to a reasonable number
of requests per access token.
The nice thing about
Firebase, because it's
a long-lived connection,
is you are effectively
unlimited for read
requests because you should
establish a single
connection and just let
that ride for a pretty
long period of time.
So we encourage
you to go that way.
Things to look out for
while you're testing.
Cover the expected cases.
That includes things like
users have multiple structures.
You should let them
pick which one you
want to turn the
lights on in, probably.
Users may have multiple
thermostats per structure,
although a lot don't.
Users may have
multiple Nest Protects.
And like we talked about before,
the thermostats themselves
have a variety of wiring
combinations that provide,
some have fans, some
have air conditioners,
some have heat pumps, some
have stage two heat pumps.
But you should test as wide
a range of permutations
of physical hardware as you
can using the virtual devices.
Also make sure you
handle the unexpected.
So network connectivity
gets disrupted,
clients disconnect,
clients reconnect.
Make sure you take
that into account.
Rate limits can occur.
We don't have a fantastic story
for simulating rate limits.
But if you do get a 429
response for rate limit,
make sure you handle
that appropriately.
Once you get above
a certain size,
we do have a lightweight
client review process in place.
And this isn't to
stifle innovation.
This is just to
make sure that once
people get above sort
of mass market size,
that we have some review
that people are meeting
UI guidelines, that the
thing actually works,
that it's not totally
detrimental to the Nest
service.
This is the token cap
request that comes into us.
We look at things.
If it passes muster, then
we up your token limit
to however much you need.
If it's not covered
before, all this stuff
is available right now
at developer.nest.com.
You can go there today.
We have many, many
developers already signed up.
You create an account.
You can create your clients.
Provide the scopes you need and
the justifications for those.
There's a detailed set
of documents on testing.
There's guidelines
for deployment.
And there's also forms to
go request more tokens when
your app gets above
a certain size.
The documentation we
provided is pretty extensive.
We've worked with a lot of
people for reviewing this.
We've done a lot
of work internally
to have people inside Nest
come try to build integrations
on the Nest platform.
So we think we have
is pretty good.
There's a ton of it there.
If you don't get your
questions answered there,
we also have the Stack
Overflow Nest API tag.
We will be happy to answer
any other questions.
Thanks, guys.
I'm going to hand it
back to Matt to wrap up.
MATT ROGERS: Thanks, Mark.
Yeah.
Pretty exciting to be here.
And pretty excited to see what
you guys are all going to do.
And as he said, we put together
a pretty comprehensive program.
There's a reason why it took us
the better part of eight months
to get here.
We wanted to think about the
whole end to end experience.
Think about authentication.
About user privacy,
about being transparent.
I think we may be one
of the first companies
to ever do this.
Everyone uses OAUTH, but
most of the time, when
you use OAUTH, it
says, hey, this app
wants access to
your contact list.
And well, why does it want that?
So I think putting
the extra mile
in having developers
say what they
want to use the
data for, I think,
gives users that additional
comfort about their privacy.
And I encourage everyone to
be honest and open about this.
Because we're going to
be auditing it, too.
So again, everything,
as Mark said,
is available on
developer.nest.com.
We went through kind
of extensive review
internally with our
early beta partners
to make sure we have a really
comprehensive set of documents
for you guys to use.
Big and small.
Anybody can work with Nest.
Any platform, iOS, Android, web,
hardware, software services,
the whole gamut.
No hardware changes required.
And you guys can start today.
Again, summing it up.
Thermostat control.
Working with Nest Protect
and listening for those
alarms states.
Home and Away, ETA.
I think these are really
powerful concepts.
And I'm really excited
to see what we do.
I mean, this is just
the beginning for Nest.
There's going to be hopefully
thousands of applications
that we haven't even
thought of and things you
guys are going to build
over the coming year.
Really excited to see
what you guys will do.
And again, this is
just the beginning.
I can see this being
a platform that we use
and we leverage as
we add more products.
What other cool
features will we add?
Again, thank you
all for being here.
I really appreciate it.
One last thing.
So we had a long history
getting to where we are.
And Nest is doing really
well, and being part of Google
has been amazing.
But getting here
was a long road.
And I can imagine for a lot
of you guys getting started,
you don't necessarily
have all the networks
that we had to get started.
So thinking about that,
my co-founder, Tony, and I
were talking about,
well how can we
make this program
completely comprehensive?
So we partnered with some of
our early investors, Kleiner,
Perkins, and Google
Ventures, to create
a fund for Nest developers.
So as you guys are
building your apps,
if you think you need funding
to build your company,
that's available.
And applications are online.
Thoughtfulthingsfund.com.
And the KP and GV guys are
going to check it out and start
funding companies
that work with Nest.
So I think it's a
really good thing.
I think it's one of
the first times this
has been done in the home.
So I'm really excited to see
what kind of new companies come
out.
Again, as I asked
earlier, there's
a lot of things
that could be built.
And a lot of
companies that could
be started in this industry.
So thanks again for coming.
And I'm really excited to
see what you guys build.